contributions at this point I'd like to
remind you that in line with the aussies
rules of procedure the speaking time is
limited to three minutes let me now give
the floor to the first speaker on my
list the distinguished representative of
Finland his Excellency Matti Ottoman
Deputy Minister you have the floor sir
Thank You mr. chairperson Thank You mr.
logic and your whole team for your
excellent chairmanship of the OECD you
see this year the security situation in
Europe has unfortunately worsened in
recent years working the OSI continues
to be overshadowed by the ongoing
conflict in Ukraine last month my
minister visited Kiev and the contact
line in stanitsa luhanska in eastern
Ukraine and witnessed the completed
design engagement we welcome these
positive steps but more is needed and we
stress Russia's responsibilities here
Russia's in the illegal annexation of
Crimea and Sevastopol as well as actions
in and around Ukraine are not acceptable
we are all concerned about the human
rights situation in Crimea we must
continue to work towards the solution of
protracted conflicts in the OSCE area
the Republic of Moldova in Georgia and
in the Quranic Arabic this is the core
mandate of the OSC recently we have
business deterioration of the security
situation along along the administrative
border boundary line with South Ossetia
region of Georgia we urge all relevant
actors to refrain from actions that
could escalate the situation we call on
Russia to fulfill its obligation under
the EU mediated ceasefire agreed
of 12th of August 2008 despite our
differences or actually also because of
them the relevance of the OSC is evident
both as a valuable actor in solving and
preventing conflicts as well as
normatively the lung along among
international actors the OSE and
estimate M are in central role in
Ukraine for the OSC participating states
though we see commitments and principal
are part of the rules-based
international order we are all to
respect and implement our existing
mutual commitments starting from
Helsinki final act and the Charter Paris
though EC needs to address those issues
that most affect our security we wish
the structured dialogue to continue
producing small but necessary steps
towards common understanding overseas
confidence-building measures are
valuable however they do have to respond
to the present day needs stemming from
changes in security environment as well
as technology this is why the DNA
document modernization is important and
justified I hope that participating
states can start negotiations on the
modernization based on the proposal that
Finland among others has put forward the
Open Skies treaty ensures transparency
and predictability health verification
and enhances trust between all the
participants we have to make sure that
dopers sunslice
rights
all right thank you
I think his Excellency Martin and I now
give the floor to his Excellency Joseph
Bordeaux font Ellis a representative of
the European Union for Foreign Affairs
and security policy and vice-president
of the European Commission Minister dear
friends I sign warmly there's no
lecturers are enough in my frame use
logic and his team for the excellent
work done to this year and extend my
best wishes to the incoming your opinion
to your and also thanks Eden pull-up for
putting forward the candy that you have
for chairmanship in 2021 and 20 this
being my first international conference
after taking office I wish to assure you
of my engagement to work closely with
all of you and to ensure our European
continent develops into a pillar for
peace prosperity and justice for the
rest of the world this practice lava
ministerial meeting must help advance in
this direction across all our dimensions
providing real added value for the
organization
this year developments have amply
confirm the need to restore respect for
Aussie principles and commitments
safeguarding territorial integrity the
mutual respect remain our guiding
principle and relevant as ever do you is
ready to actively support our efforts as
part of our commitment to a multilateral
group a soda and the European security
architecture
I think we had a welcome to recent post
positive developments in Ukraine the
upcoming Normandy for summit brings hope
for the result-oriented increased
dialogue at the same time the core of
the conflict remains gracias violation
of international law a nursery
principles through illegal election of
Crimea and Sevastopol an aggression in
northern Ukraine there the work of the
special monitoring mission to with
European Member States contribute more
than two thirds and personal and budget
is invaluable and must enjoy full save
and conditional and unhindered taxes
rather grain in accordance with its
mandate humanitarian access and
protection for the civilian population
and critical infrastructure must also be
ensured let's remember the challenging
world the calm protected conflict in our
area whether in Georgia Moldova Nauru
Kiribati come to be solve only in line
with the principles together with its
member states European Union continues
to believe that it's vital to modernize
our OC political military toolbox must
not ability be in a document in order to
increase military stability transparency
and predictability
they also his comprehensive concept of
security highlight the vital role of the
human dimension and in particular the
importance of respect for the
fundamental freedom for our common
security the backsliding of human rights
the restriction imposing fundamental
freedoms and the growing intolerance
agassi area need to be addressed
partially yet mr. chairman dear friends
they all sees the world larger regional
security organization we are very proud
to be part of it and will continue
respecting and restore
in good faith you can be assured that
you will continue to actively play its
part
I thank his Excellency Joseph Burrell
Fonterra
High Representative of European Union
for Foreign Affairs and security policy
and vice-president of the European
Commission the next speaker on